[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
فائده للجانب الصيني انه يتجنب الحواجز
الجمركيه والموانع السياسيه اللي موجوده
الان مع الدول الاوروبيه والغربيه بشكل
عام ومع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذا
سيساعدها انها تصدر منتجات بشكل بشكل
مفيد للمملكه العربيه السعوديه وايضا في
حوافز وموقع الجغرافي للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه على ثلاث قارات واصولها الى
منطقه الشرق الاوسط وافريقيا والى اوروبا
هذا يسهل للمنتجات الصينيه
[موسيقى]
انه انه جد بالاستثمارات زياده
الاستثمارات العربيه السعوديه وايضا
الجانب الصيني وهو مستفيد انه يتجنب
الحواجز والموانع السياسيه هذه فائده
مشتركه ما بين الطرفين
ما هي المنتجات في اول اللي اعلنها سمو
وزير الطاقه امس انه يستهدفون صناعه
ايضا في التكنولوجيا في الذكاء الاصطناعي